[MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHOOSH]
[CLICK]
Hello, and welcome to
"Apps Script Office
Hours." I'm Eric Koleda.
I'm a member of the developer
relations
team for Apps Script.
And this is our weekly episode
where we come, we tell you the
news about Google Apps
Script, and we
also answer your questions.
So let's get started with
the release notes.
So the Apps Script team, we
make releases on kind of a
regular basis.
And we publish kind of a release
notes that gives you a
quick overview of what's changed
in Apps Script over
that amount of time.
And so we did have a release
that came out on the 13th.
That was just yesterday.
And it's a pretty small release,
but some interesting
things in there.
So the first is that we added
the ability to disable SSL
certificate validation
in the SOAP service.
So recently--
if you scroll back down through
the release notes,
you'll see that a couple weeks
ago, we made it so that the
default for all of our HTTP
requests that are made via
Apps Script to an outbound
server, by default now, the
SSL certificate of the server
that you're making the request
to is validated.
And if it's non-valid, we'll
throw an exception.
Now, there are some cases
where maybe you want to
connect to a server.
It's your own server.
You know that it's yours, and
it's not compromised.
But the SSL cert is just not
valid, or it's self-signed.
In this case, we've provided
an override in UrlFetch--
that service-- to disable this
validation so you could still
make the request.
But for the SOAP service, we
didn't have that flag.
So there's now a flag in there
so that if you're making a
SOAP request to a server with
your own certificate or that
you know that you trust, you
can disable validation and
it'll go through.
Also in this release, we fixed
a very hot issue, a very
critical issue for a lot of
people, which was that
GmailApps and MailApps sendEmail
function has the
ability to pass in
a name override.
So this is kind of not an email
address override, but
kind of the display name
that shows up in
various email clients.
And for a while, that was
broken, where it was not
taking that into account, and
just showing your default name
for your user account--
your email account.
And now it's working again.
So that's been fixed.
And then, something that's
actually a really, I think,
nice usability fix for me
is if you've worked with
Libraries--
which is an Apps Script feature
that allows you to
define a reusable set of code,
package it up as a library,
and then share it among many
other scripts that you have--
when you were doing an update to
your library, and you cut a
new version of your library,
that version number wouldn't
show up in the dialogue for
other scripts for sometimes 5
or 10 minutes.
The caching was too long.
So they've now removed that so
that when you make an update
to a library, it shows up as
being available in other
scripts almost immediately.
So I think those are
some pretty cool
features and fixes.
And stay tuned to the Release
Notes page for more
information about releases
that are coming up.
So something that didn't make
the release notes but is also
an interesting piece of news
is that we have added the
ability to change the splay URL
for the Chrome Web Store
apps that you publish
via Apps Script.
So Apps Script has the ability
to automatically, very easily,
just a couple clicks, publish a
web app that you've made and
publish it to the Chrome
Web Store.
So this integration has been
around for a little while.
But we've now upgraded
it a little bit.
So what it was before is that
when I published to the Chrome
Web Store, the URL that showed
up was kind of like, this web
app comes from-- and it
would typically show
your company's URL.
Since all Apps Script web
apps are hosted off
script.google.com, it would
show your exceedingly long
script.google.com URL as the
kind of validated or verified
URL in the Chrome Web Store.
And while this is true, while
that is where your script's
being served from, it doesn't
really serve the purpose of
that field, which was to kind
of give, perhaps, your
company's approval
for this web app.
Like, OK, this web app was
made by mysite.com.
And therefore, whatever
credibility My Site has is
then given to that web app
in the Chrome Web Store.
So what we've allowed you to do
now is for any URL that you
own, a verified URL that belongs
to your account, you
can now use that instead of
the script.google.com URL.
So if you look at my sample
app that I created in the
Chrome Web Store--
Feed+--
you'll see, before, where it
used to have script.google.com
slash, slash, slash, et cetera,
it now just says
erickoleda.com, since that
is a domain that I own.
And so this is a little tweak.
But we think it's an important
one for two reasons.
Like I said, it allows you
to take whatever trust or
credibility that you have in
your domain and apply it to
your app, created
in Apps Script.
But more importantly, this
display here of how many users
have installed it, that actually
got pushed off the
screen before.
There wasn't enough screen real
estate to fit both the
really long script URL and
that piece of data.
So it actually allows this, I
think, important piece of data
of how many users you have to
come back into the screen.
So that's another thing that
we've done recently that we
think makes Apps Script even a
better platform for building
web apps, specifically a web
app like Feed+, which is
small, targeted, and
you want to utilize
at some Google services.
We think that's a good use
case for Apps Script.
All right, so that's about all
the news we have for today.
Let's answer some questions.
So do we have anybody
in the Hangout?
Let's see.
Nobody in the Hangout--
aw.
All right, so we are
broadcasting at a special date
and time today.
So I expected that people
might not have
gotten the memo in time.
But we do have a question on
our Moderator page that
someone submitted beforehand.
So we can take a look at that.
So the question here is, "I'd
love to expand the integration
of some of the Google Apps and
workflows we are building
deeper into the Google APIs."
And he says, "No
OAuth 2.0 is a bummer.
Should I continue to
call App Engine?
Or will it make my year to have
that come down the pipe
sometime soon?"
So we do have--
Apps Script has the deep
integration with a lot of
different Google services.
So we have Spreadsheets,
and Contacts, and
Calendar, and Gmail.
And a lot of those are bundled
up into what we call the
"default services." And the
default services are things
that have easy-to-use,
kind of custom Apps
Script interfaces for--
and then, we also
expose a series
called Google API services.
These are ones that are kind of
existing APIs that you can
use outside of Apps Script--
that we've kind of just made it
a little bit easier to use
within Apps Script.
It's still very much based on
the same external format that
you would have seen if you
had use it externally.
So it's the same method names,
the same object names.
It's not kind of a rewrite
of the API.
It's the API directly,
which is kind of
built into Apps Script.
And we have those for a couple
other services, like the URL
shortening service.
And the Tasks API, I believe,
is implemented that way.
But there's still a bunch more
Google services that aren't
present in that list and that
you may want to use.
And many of those do
require OAuth 2.0.
And in the past, when we've
said you want to integrate
with a Google service that's not
currently in Apps Script
or a third-party service, the
recommendation is use UrlFetch.
It's a generic ability within
Apps Script to make a request
to a URL, get back
the results.
If it's JSON, you
can parse it.
If it's XML, you can parse
it, et cetera.
But, yeah, the bummer here, as
the person pointed out, is
that that UrlFetch doesn't
support OAuth 2.0 today.
And OAuth 2.0 is definitely the
standard for authorization
and authentication that a lot
of APIs are moving to, both
outside of Google and within.
So it is something that we're
aware of-- that there is a
lack of this feature and that
it would be nice to have.
But at the moment, there's no
kind of immediate timeline or
plans that I can give for when
we could expect to see that in
Apps Script.
But it's definitely something
that we're looking towards.
And we definitely want to make
it available, just so that
these kind of use cases are
there and are possible.
All right, so I don't see any
other questions here.
And do we have anybody
else in the Hangout?
Looks like a no.
All right, well, this could be
a very short episode of "Apps
Script Office Hours" today.
But let me just end it with
a few more announcements.
So one is that one of my
colleagues, Arun, who works
here in our New York office as
well, tomorrow, November 15--
that's correct.
He will be hosting a Hangout
On Air, which is an
introduction to Google
Apps Script.
Now, this is being run by the
Google Enterprise team.
But it's open to anybody who
wants to tune in and watch
because a Hangout On Air is
broadcast via YouTube so that
anyone can watch it live inside
their Google+ Stream.
So if you are someone who's new
to Apps Script, and you
didn't understand the first half
of this "Office Hours"
today, this would probably
be a good place to go.
Arun is a great presenter.
And he'll take you through,
kind of at a higher level,
what Apps Script is, what its
capabilities are, why you'd
want to use it.
And I think he's even going
to show off some of the
capabilities and just how easy
it is to get started.
So if you're new to Apps Script,
tune in tomorrow, 2:00
PM Eastern time, as
you can see here.
And I think it'll be recorded.
So if you miss that specific
showing, you can go back and
watch it later.
And then, keeping on with the
things that we're doing here
on the team, also tomorrow, and
at a very similar time--
2:30-- so these will be
competing with each other--
is another Apps Script
presentation that Ikai and a
colleague, Nick, on the
Analytics team, are going to
be doing together, where they're
going to specifically
cover the integration
between Google Apps
Script and Google Analytics.
So we did a blog post, a guest
post, from Nick a couple of
weeks ago-- maybe
a month or two--
showing off his really nice
integration between Apps
Script and Analytics.
It's available in the
script gallery.
So you can play with it there.
I think it's called--
it's got the word
"magic" in it.
And it almost is magic.
If you're an Analytics
user, these
abilities are pretty cool.
But it allows you to, really
quickly, define, like, reports
on your analytics data and
bring them into a Google
Spreadsheet.
And then, once they're in a
spreadsheet, you know the kind
of capabilities you have--
the collaboration, creating
charts, sharing your data,
doing calculations,
pivot tables.
There's a lot of power there.
So this is a really cool
integration and a really cool
way to kind of keep the data
fresh too, because you could
do a one-time export
for some data.
But with this integration,
you can have it
on a recurring basis.
So that was a really popular
blog post he put out and a
really popular script.
And so we're just going to dive
even deeper into it in a
"Google Developer Live" episode
tomorrow, 2:30 Eastern
time, with Ikai and Nick.
So if you're an Analytics power
user, or you want to
know more about this
integration, I'd tune in to
that as well.
And likewise, it's going
to be recorded.
So if you want to watch
both, don't worry.
You can always watch one
of them after the fact.
All right, don't see
anymore questions.
Don't see anymore Hangout
participants.
I think that's going to
wrap it up for today.
Once again, I'm Eric Koleda.
And this has been "Apps Script
Office Hours." Tune
in again next week.
And if you have any questions,
you can always reach out to us
on Stack Overflow
or on Google+.
Thanks for joining.
[MUSIC PLAYING]